أدرك على الرغم من الوضع
أنه لا يمكنني تسليم التفويض الذي
انتخبت فيه من قبل الحزب المحافظ
، لذا فقد تحدثت إلى
جلالة الملك لإبلاغه أنني
أستقيل من رئاسة الحزب المحافظ
هذا الصباح التقيت برئيس الحزب.
لجنة 1922 سيدي جراي وبرادي
لقد اتفقنا على أنه ستكون هناك
انتخابات قيادة تكتمل في
غضون الأسبوع المقبل ،
وهذا سيضمن أننا نظل على
طريق تقديم خططنا المالية
والحفاظ على الاستقرار الاقتصادي لبلدنا
والأمن القومي.
كرئيسة للوزراء حتى
تم اختيار خليفة ، شكرًا لك
الأخبار العاجلة الرئيسية من
المملكة المتحدة ، أصبحت ليز تروس الآن أقصر
رئيسة وزراء في تاريخ بريطانيا
في أه 44 يومًا و 45 يومًا أه فقط تحاول
اكتشاف كل شيء لحظة غير عادية
في التاريخ البريطاني